right-wing journalists like wood little
would like you to think they believe in
free speech in his case racist columns
joking that Asian voters can't tell the
difference between choosing a brinjal
bajji side order or filling out an
election ballot all writing I have spent
the morning trying to draw a cartoon of
a black person without being racist it's
bloody difficult especially the lips ah
he thinks a matter of principle
how ironic then that his latest
offensive rants pondered how to stop
Muslims from exercising their rights of
democratic choice my own choice of
election dates he wrote would be a day
when universities are closed and Muslims
are forbidden to do anything on pain of
Hell or something I'm glad people are
cooling out this kind of racism it
offends all at common principles of
democracy and equality but spare me the
faux outrage little and so many extreme
commentators like him have been spouting
this kind of hate for years media
organizations don't just tolerate it
they encourage it let's not wait for the
next column that crosses the line to
condemn this for what it is unacceptable
racism that's neither satirical nor
funny before I go into my argument you
said rod was a right-wing Genesis he was
a member of the Labour Party until 2016
and was suspended for writing about
anti-semitism within the party but they
go that's just by the way more about you
Carol if you think he's not right-wing
because I think most people recognize
that his narrative is right-wing but
anyway okay so I want to take you back
to when you wrote about Nelson's column
new call for you trashed one of this
country's great heroes you said he was a
racist and a white supremacist and and
it provoked national outrage people
thought your comments were offensive
many said they were opponent even you
were accused at that point being racist
by some there was a professor historian
called Jerry white he actually said what
you'd said was comparable to Isis in
Iran destroying a culture they believed
was on xx at unacceptable and thinking
it could be a race you called what she
said pure alledon way
anyway but my point is it's extreme
language that's what we're talking about
is it not and yet so you were allowed to
tell your truth as unacceptable and
offensive as that was to some people and
yet rod little is not allowed to
satirize we you know what he was doing
if you you it was it was did you you
might not find it funny to put to
imagine that rod little is saying let's
disenfranchise Muslim voters silly
I noticed you skipped over the part in
your inter way you mentioned what he'd
said about students do you read what he
said about students was that he wanted
them drugged with horse tranquilizers
and skunk and actually sent away for the
day do you seriously believe he meant
that this is satire F where you might
not like it
satire isn't often funny but that's what
it is satyr and you want to deny him the
right to say what you have the right
thing I disagreed wave off whirlwind
that Nelson column because I would like
you to name a historian who disagrees
with the facts of my column because
there isn't one
because what I wrote was based on an
agreed history relevant relevant
this was my column wasn't satire it was
I didn't say pointing out historical
facts about Nelson didn't it was and by
the way I did not call for his statue to
be removed I said we should talk I think
I think what I'd like to say is we all
accept that some jokes gone wrong funny
and some jokes are politically incorrect
but still managed to be funny somehow
and that's the art and and that you know
the magic of comedy I personally have
committed some of you know about this
thread I tried to give a funny speech at
a point that an occasion that she'll
remain unnamed and the worst thing I've
ever done in my life and the person that
was a target of my so-called funny
speech and rightfully so what furious
when he didn't speak to me for I can't
say more because it's
I speak for a living and it was
disastrous because sometimes drugs don't
land now I think this is quite simple
this is a case where I just don't think
this guy is generally funny but in
particular I think there are there is a
difference between look I think we have
to try and grapple with and this is not
by accident okay but you deliberately
wrote the comments we have to grapple
with the difference between bullying and
joking and sometimes when you think
you're joking you're bullying people and
sometimes you're not and if we can at
least accept that's a legitimate
question then I think I firs got a point
can I just come back just very briefly I
was once heard the great Barry Cryer I
was a dude you know brilliant funny man
and I thought I was asked to give a
roast for Barry see what rod little the
man himself says there was no hate
speech or Islamophobia whatsoever in my
piece none was meant none intended none
should be taken it was very
light-hearted series of suggestions
about when to hold an election based
upon the silly dispute over the proposed
dates for the election it was patently a
joke as Carol pointed out all I would
say on this is and this is you don't
have a right to not be offended part of
being in a society in the West is that
sometimes people say do write sketch
draw things that are as long as he and
the tone of the pieces I'm sure you have
if it was isolated like that I would
absolutely support you
I happen to know Rod little I admire his
writing I think he's on the money more
often the news not and when you read the
whole piece it is very very light and
satirical just a quick one therefore
well Fraser Nelson the editor of The
Spectator himself said the piece should
not have been published in that form so
even Fraser is accepting that the piece
wasn't completely acceptable basically
you said that this is funny because
sorry to interrupt you but is a it's
we've heard of sorry's not sorry this is
a not sorry sorry seriously suggested
that Muslims each student should be
prevented from voting then of course I
would denounce it it would be disgusting
it would be a disgusting thing to say
but rod little wasn't
doing that he was satirizing a wrangle
over the two election dates by making
deliberately absurd suggestions at the
data we have writers who disagree
passionately with each other they often
make jokes but this one was too easily
misrepresented and should not have been
published in the form that it was the
only thing I would say as one is in your
intro you said that the media not only
tolerate little they also encourage it
and I would say by you doing this topic
you're kind of encouraging this sort of
attention that rod little wants I mean
probably been in newspapers between
about a hundred and eighty years
respectfully you guys haven't and you're
wrong they do not encourage it they go
out quite rightly now editors go out of
their way to ensure they don't fall into
that exactly the kind of reaction he's
going to get with the Kate Hopkins have
Katie Hopkins have been published
calling for things I think most
reasonable people and there is a context
and I just want to show you this there
is a context this isn't rod little just
making a joke that landed flat which was
your example this is somebody who has in
recent years made a name for himself not
just being raised this generally
specifically going for this one group
Muslims people who we know are
experiencing a huge surge in hate crime
who have been demonized in an on to an
unprecedented extent in the media and
this is what someone from the Muslim
Council of Britain says about that
context for what it means what little
has a history of racism specifically
they're not exclusively targeting
Muslims he's called Muslim savages claim
that Muslims are inherently anti-semitic
and even called for extremists to blow
themselves up in predominantly Muslim
areas and yet he's still given a
platform this isn't a joke racism is
harmful it feeds into the far-right
rhetoric and ultimately editors need to
be held to account as to the pollen
to turn a blind eye to this that needs
to be an apology condemnation of racism
and a commitment that there's no room
for it in the media and this is really
the problem Carol when you compare
someone like me and the column you
mentioned that I wrote was an
anti-racist column it was saying when
there is a history of racism as there is
a Nelson's track record we should talk
about it you comparing me calling out
racism to someone being racist the two
are not you can ask them not let me ask
you a question do you really think Rod
little really believes that Muslims
should be disenfranchised do you believe
that it's not that I take the column
literally it's that it feeds into a
context where he puts out anti-muslim
messages frequently and is celebrated
for that by by by an extreme that has
gained ground